[музика]
[оплески]
ти завжди досягаєш свого ти щодня
дістаєшся безпечно додому Ти новина
отримаєш в будь-який час
маєш свіжі продукти і снідаєш смачно
виглядаєш чарівно ти знаєш що світ це
робота усіх хто працює з любов'ю
професійно-технічна освіта все працює
завдяки нам
навчайся тому що любиш
Доброго дня шановні колеги дуже рада вас
вітати на фінальному заході
програми UFO Skills Я думаю що ви також
радієте сьогодні бути все разом тут в
живому форматі побачити поспілкуватися
Я хочу нагадати просто в нас є люди і
іншомовні спікери у вас на столах є
навушники
нам барду for english
Дякую Так продовжуємо мене звати Наталія
Я сьогодні буду мудрувати наш захід і
дуже рада вітати вас сьогодні тому що
сьогодні в залі тут і насправді в нас ще
є і онлайн-трансляція на Ютубі Мені
здається зібрані всі-всі-всі люди які
займаються професійно-технічно майже всі
так
професійно-технічну освіту які роблять
для того щоб вона розвивалася щоб вона
була такою відповідала
потребам і нашого ринку ситуації в
країні Тому нам дуже радісно вас
сьогодні всіх бачити з усієї України у
залі у нас є представники профільних
міністерств та установ які працюють над
провадженням реформи
донорські організації які надавали
фінансування та експертизу представники
закладів які працювали з даною програмою
також з нами є представники
департаментів освіти та
навчально-методичних центрів з більшості
регіонів в Україні тому давайте собі
поаплодуємо і почнемо наш захід
я насправді Тут також не випадково
можливо декількома з вас навіть і
знайома в рамках проектів які ми
реалізовували я є керівною партнеркою
агенції яка називається ван хелс і
дуже-дуже пишаюся що моя команда
долучалася до реалізації двох проектів
це для того щоб популяризувати
професійно-технічну освіту один з
проектів це були комунікаційна компанія
тест-драйв професія для дівчат можливо
таку пам'ятаєте для того щоб
популяризувати професійно-технічну
освіту і в принципі боротися з
гендерними стереотипами навколо
професійно-технічної освіти а другий
проект - це навчальний курс з
комунікації для профтехів які
називаються виднокурс сподіваюся що
більшість з вас вже його пройшло якщо не
пройшло О бачите Дякую що ви підтримуєте
Якщо не прийшло То на платформі про в
техосвіти цей курс розміщений тому будь
ласка проходьте бо комунікація дуже
важливою частиною
просування
професійно-технічної освіти а сьогодні Я
рада вас всіх вітати на цьому закладі і
сподіваюся що ми сьогодні його дуже
плідно проведемо згадаємо всі досягнення
які були іще і по плануємо майбутнє тому
що незважаючи на все те що в нас
відбувається в країні Я дуже-дуже вірю в
нашу незламність нашої стійкість те що в
нас є велика майбутній і
професійно-технічна освіта зараз буду
відігравати дуже важливу роль зважаючи
на те що нам треба уже починати
відбудовувати нашу країну
Ми сьогодні будемо так говорити про
майбутнє як я вам вже сказала і разом з
партнерами які всі ці роки нам в цьому
допомагають декілька слів ви зараз скажу
про
технічні моменти
у вас в роздаткових матеріалах є
програма заходу якщо ви захочете ви
можете на неї час від часу дивитися і в
програмі заходи є весь таймінг і ми
будемо намагатися дотримуватися Щоб
вчасно піти на обід вчасно підняти всі
теми І щоб ви знали коли ви зможете
повернутися до своїх домівок друге
безпека це дуже важлива річ Ми живемо в
час війни якщо буде тривога в разі
тривоги у нас будуть спеціальні люди
представники готелі які нас приведуть в
сховище ми зупиняємо подію але
обов'язково після завершення тривоги
повертаємося сюди в зал і з того місця
де ми завершили Будемо продовжувати
дуже-дуже сподіваюся що тривоги з нами
нас сьогодні не буде але щоб ми були
готовими щоб ви знали що ми всі йдемо в
безпечне місце стосовно перекладу Я
сказала вона зараз будуть вітальні слова
у нас будуть іншомовні спікери кому
потрібен переклад у вас на столах є
навушники ви зможете їх
отримати одягнути і для того щоб
налаштувати українську мову у вас буде
двійка тобто для англомовного перекладу
одиничка для україномовного двійка з
нами також на зв'язку яке може також
говорили є учасники нашої події в
онлайні дуже дякую Що доєдналися з
Сподіваюся вона чуєте Бачите і будете
разом з нами ще важливо один технічний
момент На цьому я вже завершили наші
технічні всі речі в рамках після кожної
сесії тому що ви знаєте що в нас будуть
публічні дискусії де ми будемо
обговорювати важливі речі на тему
професійно-технічної освіти розвитку
людського потенціалу і так дальше у вас
буде можливість задати запитання нашим
спікерам у вас також є в роздаткових
матеріалах блокнотики і ручки Я вас дуже
прошу уважно слухати про що ми будемо
говорити і записувати свої запитання і
Мої колеги
до вас підійдуть це буде Артем де з
Артем напевно ззаду є він до вас підійде
за кожен столик з бере запитаннячка і я
а от Артем Да дякую і ми зможемо їх
задати нашим спікером для того щоб всі
запитання були розглянуті і ви отримали
на них відповіді
от така у нас буде сьогоднішня робота
Сподіваюся вона буде дуже плідною
надихаючи що вас буде можливість
поспілкуватися по взаємодіяти і
поплавати майбутнє тому Ще раз вітаю вас
всіх на фінальному заході програму є у
фоскіз давайте ще раз поплодуємо тому що
аплодисменти вони додають енергії
зараз пару слів скаже про програми Я
думаю що ви всі знаєте але трошечки
нагадаю і у фоскіл - це програма
підтримки реформи професійно-технічної
освіти в Україні програма підтримали
Європейський союз та його країну члени
це Німеччина Фінляндія Польща та Естонія
За що ми дуже дякуємо
нашим партнерам за те що ви підтримали
цей проект і ми змогли його реалізувати
проект стартував 2019 році і Сьогодні ми
святкуємо завершальну стадію цієї цієї
фази
продовжуємо програму впроваджують
діазетка а також організації з країн що
співвісно фінансували вибачте програму
це фінська національна агенція освіти
польський фон солідарності та управління
освіти та молодь гарно з Естонії і
основна ціль даної програми це активна
підтримка розвитку професійно-технічної
освіти як я вже сказала що це все
стартувало у 2019 році і головною метою
було адаптувати
навчання навчальні програми під ті умови
які зараз складаються і мені здається що
це напевно недаремно що в 2019 році
розпочалася зміни та реформи
професійно-технічної освіти тому що
сьогодні як напевно як Ніколи ми
розуміємо наскільки при в техосвіти є
важливою наскільки вона буде
затребуваною і Наскільки ці всі процеси
які відбулися вони є надзвичайно
важливими
і ця програма працювала в самі пілотних
регіонах Як ви знаєте це у Вінницькій
Полтавській
Запорізький Рівненський Львівський
Миколаївський та Чернівецькій області
Але коли почалася війна прямо дуже
швидко адаптувалася для того щоб
допомагати всім закладам
професійно-технічної освіти мати
можливість навчати дітей
студентів в цих нелегких умовах тому
мені здається що це також дуже важлива
річ коли програма може бути гнучкою і
змінюватись під потреби
і дуже-дуже сподіваюся що ви всі тут
відчули позитивний вплив даної даного
даної програми і на своє життя на життя
студентів і на зміни вставлені до
професійно-технічної освіти і я впевнена
що разом з партнерами далі тільки більше
Якраз зараз ми про це трошечки більше
поговоримо тому що без партнерів
неможливо би було зробити цю
програму і я задоволенням хочу запросити
на цю сцену для вітального слова
партнерів програма його фоскіз
представників партнерів програми і
запрошує до слова ви будь ласка
підходьте сідайте на стільці будемо тут
спілкуватися в такому більш
неформальному стилі пане федеріка куна
керівника відділу зовнішньої допомоги
представництво ЄС в Україні давайте
аплодисменти ми будемо вітати
пані ліс буде Мюллер хоффеди керівництво
програм співробітництва посольства
Німеччини в Україні
пана Дмитра Завгороднього заступника
міністра освіти та науки України
пане Даніеля буше директора jz до бюро в
Україні
пане Романа поклонського директора
Департаменту праці та зайнятості
Міністерства економіки України
і пані Олю Коваль керівництво під
комітету з питань професійно-технічної
освіти та фахової передвищої освіти
комітету Верховної Ради України з питань
освіти науки та інновацій
супер В нас є дуже класні
партнери спікери які нас підтримують і
Давайте тоді почнемо з вітальних слів у
вас є мікрофони є два варіанти ви можете
вставати підходити до поділу можете в
сліду в режимі отак от як ми зараз
знаходимося говорити вітання слова
власне як ви будете хотіти і я думаю що
в такому дитячому режимі ми вам буде
зручно і запрошую до слова пане федеріка
куна
керівника відділу зовнішньої допомоги
представництва юнацтва в Україні Please
Дуже дякую
Доброго ранку всім радую всіх бачити
я не буду офіційних
виступів робити якщо розуміє базова
математика розумів що для мене десь 2,5
хвилини відведено
Отже Павло Ірина
Шумик Іра
усі умовно кажучи старики програми з
якими ми працювали всі ці роки
впродовж трьох міністрів пам'ятаєте які
дискусії ми мали говорили про
необхідно розв'язати всі питання між
джерел і кфв як підібрати пілотні заклад
де і як зробити щоб все добре працювало
якими ми були наївними
багато з того часу змінилося і ковід це
кошмар був це жах був
потім війна а ми тут Ми продовжуємо все
відбувається
Україна довела що вона може продовжувати
реформи
петенція працюють реформа йде все йде
правильно по рейках не буду говорити про
результати яке досягнуті ви знаєте краще
про це не буде говорити про скільки
грошей було виділено як ЄС підтримує
країну все це відомо Я знаю ти хотів би
подякувати людей людям які у цьому брали
участь і в Україні і представники країн
донорів Німеччина Естонія Фінляндія
Польща сподівайся нікого не забув
хочу дуже подякувати всіх до долучився
до впровадження виконання програми
багато партнерів було і є не тільки
джерети дофі і так далі багато-багато
людей завдання було небо які завдання
були складні
знаєте виконання реформ навіть у мирні
Часи дуже складно дуже тяжко ніхто не
хоче тим займатися А у часи війни це ще
тяжче тому хочу ще раз подякувати всім
хто це робив і робить І наостанок хочу
подякувати колег з міністерства
За їхню щиро залученістю ці складні часи
І власне Я говорю не лише про тих хто
самому міністерству центральному апараті
але і про тих хто працює на місцях аж до
вчителів викладачів - це завжди люди які
на передньому краї цього фронту навіть у
мирні часи у них не завжди найкраще
можливості найкращий матеріали
але це ті хто це робить і саме їхня роль
багато вважає правильно вважають що саме
їхня роль у
підготовці прийдешніх поколінь
і це не до того що це люди які працюють
аби заробити там багато не заробиш на
цьому
це люди які
попадемі проти попри війні загрози вони
щодня займаються
підготовкою молодого покоління
забезпеченням економічної взаємодії Вони
ж будуть дуже важливими і під час
відновлення звісно є правники будуть
потрібні і всякі інші спеціалісти але і
робочі руки будуть ще більш потрібні і
саме ці викладачі Саме ці майстри Мають
дуже важливу місію бо вони готують Нове
покоління для завтрашньої України Дякую
вам дякую фредеріку
Сподіваюся що все буде добре дякую
Тепер хочу надати слово пані лісбет
Міллера керівниця програми
співробітництва посольства Німеччини в
Україні Будь ласка
[музика]
Дуже дякую
складно зараз говорити бо після
попереднього виступу у мене така
формальна буде очевидна промова моя я
підготувала пункти виступу
Я хочу абсолютно приєднатися до того що
сказав Фредерік хочу подякувати
партнерів
програми і партнерів від українського
уряду хочу подякувати всім хто займався
впровадженням на місцях уптнз ті хто
власне зробив можливим успіх цієї
програми
без цих людей
нічого не сталося можна знаєте багато
грошей витратити на
будь-які речі там на пошук нових людей
але треба для цього все одно люди які
вірять у реформи Їх роблять це на місцях
і тому саме їм найбільше подяка
німецька залученість у питання
реформування
профтехосвіти воно бере початок ще з
2017 року коли були
початкові перші кроки з допомогою ВПО із
сходу України і
саме тоді було закладено підвалини того
що далі сформувалися повноцінні вже
ініціативи і форс кілс
ми близько 17 мільйонів євро інвестувала
з того часу у профтехосвіту це не
питання Суми це питання тих зобов'язань
які ми на себе взяли з розвитку цієї
важливої галузі в Україні
Це абсолютно наріжний такий необхідний
камінь
української економіки сьогодні завтра
буде йдеться про розвиток молодого
покоління молоді я в Україні
з 2020 року працює на жаль це Останній
мій тиждень в Україні Мені дуже сумно
думати що надійшов час коли мені треба і
програми треба завершувати але я дуже
сподіваюся що ця робота в Україні
триватиме і Німеччина далі
долучатиметься до розвитку зокрема
навичок і вмінь професійних
професійно-технічній освіті Я вважаю що
ми далі будемо
е-е працювати і брати на це відповідні
зобов'язання у нас і програма нова є
навички для відновлення в якій ми теж як
Німеччина ми будемо брати участь і ми
будемо безумовно зважати на потреби і
ВПО і людей які їх на яких вплинула
поточна війна Будемо допомагати
інтеграції цих людей на ринку робочої
праці і хоче сьогодні запросити усіх
наших партнерів держава члена ЄС
структури ЄС
до участі у цій новій главі нашої
співпраці дякую
спорт
Дякую України
Я запрошую до слова Дмитра Завгороднього
заступника міністра освіти та науки
України будь ласка Вітаю Доброго дня
всім
це цікаво для мене бути знаєте такою
новою людиною на
заключному слові в проекті який тривав
чотири роки і
протягом останніх місяців
якими я займаюся професійно-технічною
освітою я відвідав багато закладів в
декількох регіонах України і всюди де б
я не був завжди згадують про цей проект
з вдячністю з бажаннями продовжити його
або зробити ще один такий самий і так
далі тобто
загальне враження в людей просто
надзвичайний всі з великою вдячністю
дивляться на результати цього проекту і
на всіх людей які були до нього залучені
тому в першу чергу я хочу подякувати
всім хто в цьому брав участь всім
завдяки кому це вдалося реалізувати і
так далі для мене це в першу чергу
подяка Ірині шум як я знаю скільки сил
вона вклала в цю роботу
і протягом моєї роботи в міністерстві
останні роки я Якби слідкував за тим як
багато сил і енергії вкладається саме в
цей проект
і тому я б хотів сказати що для мене є
надзвичайно важливим те які позитивні
висновки ну чи взагалі висновки можна
зробити з
Скажімо так з результатів цього проекту
які ми можемо продовжити взяти з собою
далі Наприклад ми точно розуміємо що
запровадження навчально-практичних
центрів і закупівля обладнання для них
це ну ключова активність яка була дуже
успішною і всі на всіх рівнях і регіони
і вчителі і ми відзначаємо наскільки це
є важливим тому ми плануємо це
продовжувати так само як і появу нового
бренду нової комунікації і так далі ми
теж розуміємо наскільки це було важливо
і плануємо це продовжити так само як і
кейси співпраці з бізнесом запровадження
дуальної освіти Ми зрозуміли які
величезні бар'єри існують в нашому
законодавстві які треба змінити І так
само плануємо це продовжити тому мені
здається що це є найбільший успіх
будь-якого такого складного і довгого
проекту він є цей успіх не в тому що
проект закінчується успішно а в тому що
коли він закінчується його ідеї
продовжуються оце успішний проект тому
що насправді в Україні є багато проектів
які закінчуються І коли вони
закінчуються люди просто мріють що це
нарешті вже закінчилося і ми ніколи
знову і так далі тому як на мене це
головний показник успішності що ми все
це або більшість започаткованих ідей
ініціатив плануємо продовжити з іншого
боку Ми зрозуміли наскільки
незважаючи на величезні результати і
обсяги наскільки це маленька частина від
того що треба зробити наскільки
величезний обсяг роботи ще попереду Тому
нам точно знадобиться ваша допомога всіх
присутніх всіх кого сьогодні немає всіх
хто може допомогти докластися до того
щоб масштабувати цей успіх в майбутньому
Я закликаю Не полишати цю ідею і бути
долученими до масштабування для цих
результатів до того щоб вони все ж таки
були Набагато набагато більшими в
майбутньому І наостанок я хочу сказати
дуже важливу для мене річ Мені здається
от
колега казав стосовно того що пандемія
потім війна
і
ну Я особисто вражений якби надзвичайно
стійкістю людей в цій країні в такі часи
в закладах освіти і в управліннях і так
далі
Але мені здається що для нас дуже
важливо не
робити з будь-яких подій які б не
відбувалися навколо для нас такий
ексклюз Тобто нам треба продовжувати
реформувати систему освіти це те про що
зараз скаже новий Міністр освіти це те
про що ведемо розмови з нашими колегами
з інших міністерств ми розуміємо що є
що є термінові потреби що є внутрішнє
переміщення особи і треба всім допомогти
і це перше пріоритет Але ми не можемо
сказати що цей пріоритет має перекрити
для нас ідеї і бажання робити зміни і
реформи в системі освіти і покращувати
тому що
покращувати систему освіти і робити в
ній трансформації це вимога часу і
навіть якщо ми всі можливі ресурси
вкладемо в
рятування системи прямо зараз в
рятуванні людей які цього потребують і
все це зробимо одразу після перемоги ці
люди поїдуть з України тому що вони
побачать що тут немає змін в системі
освіти тому очікування в людей і успіх
цієї країни залежить не лише від того
наскільки Ми впораємося з терміновими
потребами які ми можемо називати
якимірочниці це більше апелюю до колег з
інших країн а так само і до тих потреб в
трансформаціях які ми маємо зробити
неважливо протягом якого часу і яких
подій які будуть відбуватися навколо нас
дякую
запрошую до слова пан на Даніеля буше
директора joz бюро в Україні Будь ласка
Дуже дякую
доброго ранку і хочу подякувати іншим
спікерам на нашій панелі є
поміряти того як
люди говорять я розумію що вони кажуть
те що я хотів би можливо сказати але
хочу подякувати від імені джаз який або
впроваджувачем проекту і я
спостерігав довготривала відданість
цілям реформи відданість завданням
проекту бажання втілити його найкраще
втілити результати в не тільки в
довготривальні перспективі але і
побачити
короткострокові скажімо швидкі
результати
налаштованість команди на ці речі була
неймовірно і
Я
вдячний всій команді разом із
спонсорами і
авторами проекти друга що я хотів би
сказати що
ключова мета успішна впровадження
проекту це надійні партнери віддані
справи проекту і це не це не завжди
природна така риса її виробляють собі і
вольовим зусиллям і за це я дуже вдячний
нашим партнерам і останнє за переліком
онлайн не заважливість
це те що
треба зробити Не завершеному закладі це
по поаплодувати всім тим хто зробив
можливим цей фінальний захід
і тут ми оглядаємося назад дивимося
вперед
чесно кажучи ми працювали У важких
умовах була пандемія ковідобув
початок війни і відзначаючи нашу успіхи
ми розуміємо що
ми можемо зможемо очевидно ще успішніше
працювати за кращих перспектив і за
менших викликів довкола І німецький уряд
також дивиться на роботу чи з цією
оптимістичною точки зору можливо
минулого тижня
коли ви спостерігали за тою міжнародною
конференцією щодо інвестицій і
відновлення України а ви зрозуміли
наскільки А будуть потрібні
професійні фахові кадри будівельники
тощо і в цьому контексті наша робота
набуває надзвичайної ваги Дякую за увагу
вас запрошую пане Романа поклонського
директора Департаменту праці та
зайнятості Міністерства економіки
України будь ласка
Вітаю шановні присутні я як Дмитро
приєднався до
проекту вже коли проект приїжджав на
останню станцію свою
призначення і
відчуваю відчуваю важливість участі в
цьому заході я хочу подякувати Німеччині
Фінляндії Естонії Польщі за те що вони
створили такий проект Я користуючись
нагодою хочу
прорекламат прорекламувати ту реформу
праці якою зараз займається мінекономіки
і в тому числі такі складові які е-е
надається проект вони вони зроблять і
успішною
я займався я не нова Людина в
мінекономіки я займався охороною
безпекою та гігієною праці тепер весь
департамент праці та зайнятості це
весь соціальний блок мінекономіки Звісно
ж що Міністерство освіти та науки - це
основний бенефіціар цього проекту Але у
нас є теж достатньо інструментів у нас є
Державний центр зайнятості за допомогою
якого ми а
брали участь в цьому проекті ми
збільшили збільшили кількість робітничих
професій для навчання за ваучери вдвічі
і з приводу майбутнього будівельників і
інших професій які потрібні будуть для
відновлення України зараз Ми якраз
розробляємо
майбутню концепцію ми обраховуємо
стратегію яка модель буде потрібна для
відновлення повоєнної України і я хочу
сказати може трохи
крапля дьогтю А але ну от так от ми
вчора запустили на погодження в
Міністерства і соцпартнери нову
робітничу професію яку можна буде
отримати за ваучер це сапери
тому що і ця професія також буде
потрібна і взагалі робітничі професії
вони
здавна
останні два-три десятиліття і не така
суперечка
де можна більше грошей заробити да
будучи керівними
посадами чи на робітничих професіях і ви
знаєте До сих пір не має якогось
фінального результату і ця програма вона
дозволить
майбутнім робітникам які будуть на
робітничих професіях вони
зможуть зможуть
більше заробляти і це гарно
дякую дякую
[оплески]
таке на позитивній ноті ви завершили це
за це вам дякую і запрошую до слова пані
Ольгу Коваль з Верховної Ради України
будь ласка Доброго дня друзі мене
сьогодні фінальне слово вітальний панелі
на фінальному заході це для мене велика
честь але знаєте мене охоплюють такі
змішані відчуття Оскільки у слові у
назві нашого заходу є слово фінальний і
це є певною ностальгією оскільки
зроблено дуже багато аби система
професійної освіти розвивалась аби
розвивався ринок праці аби розвивався
людський капітал загалом
водночас це велика вдячність всім тим
хто долучився до реалізації даного
проекту
і в мене є певна впевненість тавтологія
але це не менш того що це тільки початок
тому що попереду дуже-дуже багато роботи
Я не буду перелічувати все те що
зроблено тому що моя невеличка слово
вітальне перетвориться в довжелезну
промову і про це ми сьогодні будемо
розмовляти майже цілий день просто хочу
відмітити що ми з вами подолали великий
шлях ми системно працювали ми
змінювалися ми популяризували ми
реагували на екстрені виклики такі як
сказали колеги це виклики ковіду проект
Skills з перших днів повномасштабної
війни в нас в країні тоді була відразу
надана нам допомога в для закладів
професійної освіти для внутрішнього
переміщених осіб
для нас є дуже важливими для мене як
парламентаря дуже важливими є
законодавчі зміни законодавчі зміни на
жаль не швидкий процес і вони потребують
реалізації як реалізації уряду та
реалізації в подальшому суспільству
проект єфу Skills в цьому нам надійний
партнер тому що знову ж зроблено дуже
багато для того щоб ми в подальшому
могли уже отримати такий довгоочікуваний
законопроект Про професійну освіту шлях
довгий але я впевнена ми його подолаємо
колеги я хочу подякувати кожному з вас
всіх хто приклав свою руку до реалізації
цього проекту хочу подякувати іноземним
партнерам хочу подякувати Європейському
Союзу та країнам членам в німеч
Фінляндії Польщі останні ви наші
справжні друзі особливо хочу подякувати
міністерству освіти і Пані Ірині шумік
Тому що вона є драйвером цього процесу І
на завершення Хочу наголосити на тому що
нас обов'язково чекає перемога Я надіюсь
що вона буде дуже швидко і нам потрібно
уже зараз працювати над тим щоб ми
відразу розпочали нашу відбудову друзі
наші партнери ви нам для цього дуже
потрібні Дякую вам дякую
[оплески]
Так Дуже дякую нашим партнерам хочу
сказати що разом Ми Точно непереможні і
я думаю що ми будемо чекати перемогу але
ми будемо все робити для того щоби вона
швидше приходила і щоб ми вже могли
відбудовувати Україну дуже дякую давайте
ще раз поплодуємо
Thank you so much thank you
ви нас надихнули так надихнули нам дали
такий заряд впевненості в тому що це не
просто фінальний Іван але це якийсь
початок чогось також нового власне дуже
дуже дякуємо за величезну підтримку дуже
любимо цінуємо наших партнерів бо знаємо
що тільки разом ми можемо багато все
зробити а зараз ми будемо продовжувати і
зараз ми трішечки спробуємо глибше за
більше заглибитися в результаті нашої
програми його фоскіз згадати про основні
досягнення про основні віхи про ті в
принципі речі які були зроблені в рамках
проекту тому що я більше говорила про
певні задачі які проекти були і як ми
спільно з усіма вами Зробили цей цю
програму успішну і для цього я хочу
запросити на сцену Олексій Олексюка
радника його фоскілс для того щоб він
трошечки занурив в цю програму і ми все
згадали як це було Будь ласка
[оплески]
про здоров'я шановні гості колеги друзі
експерти Я хотів би всіх вас запросити
сьогодні в подорож подорож під
назвоюсь реформи професійної освіти
якщо рухатися
Давайте так протягом цієї цієї подорожі
ми з вами накопичили багато скарбів з
якими Ми сьогодні хотіли з вами
поділитися ці скарби це знання досвід і
наші партнерські взаємини
ми хотіли сьогодні
[музика]
дозволити собі порекомендувати і
продовжити цей шлях
зараз на слайді ви бачите загальний
інформація про проект його фоскіз яка
дійсно змінила життя багатьох людей в
Україні і вважаємо що ці зміни будуть
продовжуватися адже освіта - це завжди
інвестиції майбутнє і саме освітою Ми
створюємо нове майбутнє нової України ми
були з вами в разом в часи з системних
реформ Ми також залишалися разом в часи
ковіду і падемії
часи найбільш критичних моментів агресії
Росії 22-го року і також залишаємося
разом з вами зараз
хотіли б сказати що так як наші
військові боронять незалежність нашої
держави на передньому плані на фронті ми
боремося за майбутнє кожного українця за
майбутнє нашої України
давайте разом згадаємо Як розвивалися
програма яким чином ми прийшли протягом
всього цього періоду
від старту до завершення до цього заходу
перш за все хотів би сказати що проекти
у фоскілс він базувався на трьох
ключових компонентах перший компонент -
це ми фокусувалися на підтримці закладів
професійної освіти на модернізацію
змісту освіти на створенні сучасного
освітнього середовища другим компонентом
слід вважати нашу орієнтація на
популяризацію професійного вибору
українців на
полегшення доступу до системи
професійної освіти і третім компонентом
який є Також важливим це підтримка
системних реформ в даному контексті
можемо згадати багато різних аспектів
пов'язаних з
зміною
визнанням української освіти в Європі А
також з розвитком
законодавство в сфері професійної освіти
розробки професійних стандартів
модернізації програм навчання та інше
впевнені що більше деталей і цікавих
історій можна дізнатися від наших
партнерів які звичайно можуть з вами
поділитися ними перш за все Я думаю
найбільше так як вже сьогодні
згадувалися можуть розказати про наші
освітянські ініціативи пані Ірина
Володимирівна Шумик яка
допомагала нам багато в чому
реалізовувати всі освітні проекти думаю
що пан Юрій Баланюк Голова Національного
агентство кваліфікації також може
згадати багато моментів пов'язаних з
підготовкою звіту саме сертифікація а
також розробки професійних стандартів
окремо хотіли подякувати звичайно
комітету Верховної Ради з освітою науки
в якій можуть
згадати нашу співпрацю в межах
підготовки нового законодавства про
професійну освіту звичайно треба згадати
роботодавців але я б хотів би сказати що
найбільший скарб трошки далі про який ми
будемо говорити
Хотів би також відзначити що будь-яке
партнерство це в першу чергу люди тому
ми вдячні всім партнерам Які сьогодні
долучилися і присутні онлайн чи офлайн і
будемо раді поспілкуватися з кожним з
вами з вас і отримати можливо якісь
додаткові висновки на тематичних сесіях
нашого заходу
хотів би нагадати кожному з вас що
програма ufaskills почалась приблизно
такого самого літнього дня в червні
2019 року фактично Як ви бачите на
фотографії це відбулося в іт-хабі на
Подолі де
представник євроделегації тодішній
Міністр освіти Гана Новосад
дискутувались стосовно завдань і
звичайно тоді ніхто не розумів як буде
розвиватися звичайно тоді проект
вважався ну спрямований на розвиток
системи освіти і впровадження системних
реформ наступним кроком можемо сказати
стала пандемія пандемія змінила суттєво
умови реалізації програми вона змінила
саму освіту на перший план почали
виходити питання діджиталізації почали
розробки дистанційних курсів
перенавчання разом з нашими партнерами
ми перепідготували
1800 вчителів саме для розробки
онлайн-курсів наступним кроком можна
вважати трошки знаєте після
пандемійських часів конференція у Львові
тобто
коли ми Нам вдалося зібрати разом всіх
вас 150 приблизно людей були присутні і
це Повітря спілкування надихнуло нас
рухатись далі але
знаєте життя продовжилося і програма
розвивалася в напрямку
війни лютого 22-го року
змінилася самі українці змінилася
Україна на перший план почали виходити
аспекти пов'язані з безпечністю почали
виникли нові потреби боротьбі боротьби з
блокаутами і разом з нашими партнерами
Нам вдалося створити пакет термінової
допомоги і разом з ними ми надали
приблизно
допомогу трьохстам школам по всій
Україні незважаючи на той факт що
програма початково фокусувалася на семи
регіонах ближче до цих подій ми вже
покривали всю Україну і працювали по
всіх регіонах України Хотів би також
відзначити що десь приблизно в жовтні
22-го у нас відбулася така історія як
лучання ракети в будівлю Міністерства
освіти і Відповідно ми були раді
прихистити команду Міністерства освіти у
нас в офісі і щиро вдячні за цю спільну
роботу
от приблизно такий шлях пройшла програма
якщо ми згадаємо наскільки комплексно і
наскільки часто потрібно було змінювати
змінювати
програмні цілі і активності і як
адаптивна гнучко програми на це
реагувала то можна сказати що це
унікальний досвід імплементації
надзвичайно складних проектів в сфері
професійної освіти за таких умов
Хотів би також Сказати що однією з
найбільш унікальних рис нашої програми є
у фоскіл завжди було фокусування на
конкретних людях на учнях студентах
вчителях керівниках навчальних закладів
працівниках підприємств ми завжди
ставили за пріоритет при внесення
позитивних змін у життя конкретних людей
Всі разом стояли на Європейських
цінностях відстоюючи право
вразливих груп населення допомагаючи
освітянам адаптуватися до нових умов
підтримуючи право студентів отримати
якісну освіту протягом військового
періоду часу але
Життя продовжується І я б хотів би з
вами поділитися декількома персональними
історіями Як ви бачите на слайді це
історія пов'язана з військовим часом
Коли пані
Надія Рибак
Наталя Рибак так Вибачайте викладач
заклад до зі Львова вона намагалася
адаптуватися до нових викликів і
незважаючи на той факт що заклад освіти
був закритий вона стала однією з першою
що розробляла онлайн дистанційні курси
фактично ми допомагали таким багатьом
людям з різних навчальних закладів
отримати доступ до студента тобто
допомогти їм продовжити освітній процес
і підтримати стабільність освіти
наступним прикладом можна вважати
співпрацю з роботодавцями а також
допомогу молоді в цей складний час зараз
ви бачите пану надіючу хліб яка приймала
участь у навчанні на робочих місцях в
компаніях за професією продавець
продовольчих товарів фактично протягом
складного періоду вона пройшла тренінги
і отримала декілька
ну пропозицій про подальше
працевлаштування приблизно 900 людей ми
зробили таким пілотом і спробували
інтегрувати зразу
в ринок праці полегшивши їм доступ
наступний кейс який також заслуговує
вашої уваги це історія про переселенця з
лиману з донецького регіону Володимира
шкалія який був переміщений особою у
західні регіони і був
знайшов прихисток у одному з навчальних
закладів і зараз він отримав роботу і
продовжує там Працювати ніби сплачуючи
регіональній громаді яка його прихистила
добром за добро яке він отримав Таким
чином Як ви бачите сама програма Вона
завжди орієнтувалася на конкретних людей
на при внесення змін і
я думаю що це той
аспект який ми маємо зберегти і в
майбутньому
зараз
загальна інформація чи основні
досягнення про які варто згадати в межах
програми понад близько 300 навчальних
закладів отримали допомоги і були
залучені до програми напевно в системі
професійної освіти немає жодного
викладача чи керівника навчального
методичного центру чи керівника
навчального закладу які б не долучалися
так ще інакше даю фоскелс і шановні
спікери які виступали вони також процес
згадували Хотів би також відзначити що
одним з найбільш успішних кейсів
який був ініційований програмою це
команда популяризація профтеху
популяризація цього професійного вибору
серед українців і думаю що здатність
генерувати
привабливі для молоді умови праці так як
і Міністерство економіки зараз
намагається зробити і продовжує
підтримувати такі ініціативи
Міністерства освіти є основою для
майбутнього профтеху хотів би відзначити
що За різними оцінками і використання
різного медійного контенту можемо
стверджувати що приблизно половина
населення України точно почула профтех
Хотів би також відзначити виклики на і
реакція нашої програми які ми робили
разом з партнерами
це система дистанційного навчання
програма долучалася до створення
онлайн-контенту і наповнення цієї
програми звичайно ще є багато роботи
щодо розвитку цієї платформи Звичайно
потрібно
знаходити і розвивати і нові
спеціалізації курси але з впевненістю
можемо сказати що популярність вона
здобуває і
продовжує зростати окремо хотів би
відзначити системний внесок в підтримку
реформ в Україні
незважаючи на складні часи програма
продовжувала системні зміни тобто
протягом періоду пандемії протягом
періоду війни Ми намагалися продовжити
удосконалення і розробки освітніх і
професійних стандартів модернізації
програм навчання підготовки звіту про
визнання національної рамки кваліфікації
і її співставлення з європейською рамкою
кваліфікації а також разом з нашими
партнерами працювали над іншими
складовими
складовими реформи
нам Шкода що не всі а
Вибачайте ще один момент хотів би
підкреслити це аспект пов'язаний з
масштабом самої програми на цю Як ви
бачите ми провели велику кількість
різних заходів з усіх регіонах України
якщо подивитися
фокусування на семи регіонах які зараз
від змінчені на карті Вони повністю були
якби обмеження були подолені і ми
працювали по всіх регіональних центрах
але так чи інакше загальна кількість
заходів
у нас було понад більше 700 і як ви
бачите гендерний показник так також
важливий і приблизно 55 тисяч учасників
долучилися до тих заходів що можна
вважати досить успішною компанією для
профтеху
нам Шкода що не всі наші партнери і не
всі наші колеги можуть сьогодні
доєднатися до нас у Києві а це означає
що дехто з вас з них знаходиться онлайн
Я впевнений вони слідкують за нами але
відповідно до
моєю ролі зараз я хочу подякувати від
імені всіх наших колег
в першу чергу людям і командам які
стоять за цими роботами за цими
активностями
на цьому шляху ми співпрацювали з
великою кількістю
викладачів експертів представників
бізнесу директорів компанії ми вдячні
всім у кожному з вас що Ви принесли
частину своєї енергії як своєї
експертизи в реалізацію всієї цієї
програми фактично
заклади освіти і керівники ви є основним
скарбом системи освіти яка Ну який треба
берегти і цінувати окремо хотіли
подякувати нашим партнерам по
імплементації неможливо переоцінити
внесок який
зробили наші фінські колеги розвиваючи
різні онлайн-курси модернізуючі програми
навчання фінська національна агенція
освіти дуфі
також окремо подякуємо польському фонду
солідарності управління освіти та молоді
харно колеги разом Нам вдалося створити
потенціал для формування нового
професійного європейського українця Я
впевнений що в майбутньому цей потенціал
національні партнери будуть
використовувати незважаючи на те що ми
поширили нашу активність я хочу згадати
все-таки регіони тому що регіональні
обласні адміністрації А зараз вже
військові адміністрації вони працювали
над системним впровадженням цих
інвестицій наближаючи всі наші роботи до
конкретних людей в регіонах
залучаючи громади тому хотів би
подякувати
Чернівецький Львівський Вінницький
Полтавський Запорізький Миколаївських
областей ваша робота на місцях дійсно
була неоціненна на завершення відзначив
що ця програма є результатом спільних
зусиль як вже зазначалося
єврокомісії Фінляндії Німеччини Польщі
та Естонії окремо хотіли подякувати
делегації Євросоюзу в Україні а саме
пані Вірі Рибак яка
відповідає за сектор освіти і науки Я
думаю багато активностей цієї програми
просто не відбулося без таких людей які
нас оточували
безперечно всі посольські установи
країна-учасників долучалися і
інвестували багато зусиль в реалізації
цієї програми
тому Шановні колеги я щиро вас вітаю на
закриті цієї програми І
запрошую вас всіх долучитися до
подальшої
обговорення на секційних дискусіях які
ми будемо мати пізніше
дякую
[оплески]
[музика]
Я думаю що ви також
згадали як це було і це відео також нам
дало можливість ще зануритися там дуже
дякую за те що ви
зануритися в проект
Олексію зроблено було дуже-дуже багато
за 3,5 роки звичайно тому я думаю що є
чим пишатися скільки онлайн курсів його
офлайн скільки зустрічей
розробка стандартів і в принципі
допомога
закладам до того щоб вони могли
функціонувати працювати в Нових умовах
тому дуже-дуже сподіваюся що це слід
який
залишить програмою фоскіз він буде
дуже-дуже довго І як говорив пан Дмитро
що багато речей буде взято в роботу і
дальше буде продовжуватися тому що
англійською дуже гарно слово я сестрі на
білий тій проекту Та бо сталі з проекту
Мені здається це основна річ яку би мала
всі розвивати всіх прое які фінансується
донорами або партнерами та потім вони
надалі реалізовуються в країні і ми
зараз до речі також про це трошечки
поговоримо тут всі згадували пану Ірину
шубік зараз будемо з нею говорити про
про професійно-технічну освіту про те
які зараз є
потреби у нас на ринку як вони
змінюються як вони формуються і в
принципі наскільки освіта буде
відповідати Та я зараз буду закликати
вас до слова і буду запрошувати сюди на
панельну дискусію
пано мінну хакарайнен радницю з питань
освіти посольства Фінляндії в Україні
Будь ласка плюс
давайте аплодувати Ірина Шумик
генеральний директорка директорату
професійної освіти Міністерства освіти і
науки України
там Юрія баланюка Голова Національного
агентства кваліфікації України
пані лілії грабовську керівницю
управління професійного навчання та
міжнародного співробітництва
державної служби зайнятості
і Павла Кобзаря експерта проекту і
фоскіз і як заступника міністра освіти з
15 по 19-й рік насправді та
пан Павло з командою все підготували і
наступна команда вже з 19-го року почали
реалізовувати цей проект а тому Здається
це ми також просталість якщо ми говоримо
про сталість то це є дуже дуже важлива
річ так і ми зараз будемо з вами Я хочу
ще раз нагадати про те що ви слухаєте
дискусію я буду задавати запитання нашим
каналістам і
USA translation
А ви думаєте про те Які би ви запитання
хотіли задати Можливо у вас є якісь
думки з цього приводу про що ми будемо
говорити А ми будемо говорити про про те
що в нас сьогодні відбувається в
навчанні ми залученням кваліфікованих
конкурентноспроможних людей до праці на
ринок України щоб вони тут вчилися тут
залишалися тут відбудовували Україну і
наскільки там професійно-технічна освіта
в цьому процесі є важливою тому що
насправді я вам чесно скажу я багато
модерую займаюся великою кількістю
різноманітних
темами в сфері соціальної сфері освітній
і так дальше але вперше будемо дарувати
на тему професійно-технічну освіту пряма
ж дуже цікаво поговорити послухати
подивитися на трошечки ширший контекст
ти зрозуміти наскільки це
професійно-технічна освіта є важливою
тому що коли ти приїжджаєш за кордон вам
скажу в Німеччині основні рекламні
банери і так дальше вони всі стосуються
професійної технічної освіти тобто
вступні кампанії просування професії там
електрика будівельника і так дальше
Німеччина їдеш по трасі обвішений все
банерами дуже Чому Тому що це
затребувані це професії які
дуже поважаю це в суспільстві і
насправді на це великі багато країн
робить велику ставку Тому що це є основа
розвитку економіки впевнена що в нашій
країні також так буде вже є а може ще
немає але точно так буде і сподіваюся Ми
сьогодні про це поговоримо чому це
важливо і куди рухатися ви пишіть
блокнотиками в нас є колеги Які у вас
буде збирати з онлайну також будемо
задавати і Давайте тоді почнемо з
першого запитання
яка в нас сьогодні я хочу задати це
запитання пані лілії напевно тому що
завжди якщо ми говоримо про освіту і в
даному випадку перепрофесійно-технічну
освіту то вона пов'язана з тим які
потреби на ринку а що відбувається
сьогодні на ринку праці А що
відбувається зайнятістю у зв'язку з
війною переміщенням
внутрішньо переміщеними особами втратою
роботи і так дальше І потім поговоримо
як відповідає на це професійно-технічна
освіта отже яка сьогодні ситуація на
ринку праці які професії затребувані і
наскільки проект його фоскіз вам
допомагав зрозуміти визначити ці потреби
Ну і на них реагувати будь ласка Я вас
вітаю
шановні друзі Дякую за сьогоднішнє
запрошення на цей фінальний захід
фінальний захід проекту UFO Skills
насправді так Державна служба зайнятості
є Як то кажуть активними ігроком щодо
регіональних та ринку праці України
Взагалі
спільно з UFO Skills ми проводили
дослідження ринки праці це є робота яка
проводилась неодноразово це проект який
почався ще з 2020-го року було визначено
10 регіонів України в яких проводилась
дослідження регіональних ринків праці
вже в стані
військовому який набула наша Україна в
минулому році за допомогою проекту UFO
Skills було проведено дослідження ринку
праці будівельної галузі тому що це було
і є і післявоєнні відбудові України буде
скажемо так достатньо актуа для України
саме для відбудови Ми отримали потрібні
навички для наших кваліфікованих
робітників отримали потрібні професії
для роботодавців і як вже казав пан
Роман в нас є багато інструментів
інструментів на рівні держави які
дозволяють
покращити стан як професійної підготовки
як перепідготовка як підвищення
кваліфікації різних категорій осіб щодо
ринку праці насправді в цьому періоді
часів в Україні можу сказати що дуже
багато В нас є категорія осіб яка є
внутрішньо переміщеною категорією яка в
багатьох регіонах потребує
перепідготовки дуже багато внутрішнього
приміщених осіб які є
безробітними які є зареєстрованими в
службі зайнятості мають вищу освіту і
наразі потребують в зв'язку з
переміщенням перепідготовки саме за
робітничими професіями так як наразі в
відповідні основним І такими найбільш
затребуваними є професії
робітничі які є робітники з інструментом
які є робітники обслуговуючі такі як
водії такі як Трактористи насправді
сільськогосподарські підприємства зараз
Мають дуже велику потребу в саме такий
фахівцях що стосується
фахівців з інструментами це
електрогазозварники які мабуть завжди
скільки
я її себе пам'ятаю і на рівні державної
служби зайнятості є офіційна Інформація
що це є така професія яка є найбільш
затребувана така ж як і водії також це є
логістична система наразі дуже
потребують
логістика водії
пересування Україною для різних
категорій водіїв саме
професійно-технічну освіту надасть змогу
на рівні держави як перекваліфікувати
наших громадян які мають наразі потребу
в цьому Так і надати їм можливість бути
Як то кажуть конкурентноспроможними на
ринку праці профтехосвіта є першою Вона
має бути першою тому як для відновлення
країни насправді робітничу професію
робітничок кваліфікації є дуже потрібним
і є дуже популярними
Дякую
нас ще буде з вами серія серія завдання
але дякую що ви задали тон про те які є
затребувані професії пані Ірино А от в
контексті затребувань ми зараз говорили
тільки які на зараз я затребування ми ще
про майбутнє далі поговоримо як як
професійно-технічна освіта система
реагує на ці потреби на сьогодні і чи є
якась візія реагування на потреби завтра
якщо повертатися до питання як то я би
сказала активно і це мабуть те що
вирізняє систему професійної освіти це
велика жага і бажання і взагалі втрата
будь-якого страху та Тобто це та система
яка нічого не боїться треба буде плисти
попливемо треба полетіти значить будемо
літати і це вирізняє тут в залі сидять
керівники закладів професійно-технічної
освіти які були в пілоті
багато що трансформувалось за ці чотири
роки але я щаслива що мала нагоду
спостерігати за їхньою трансформацією та
кожного року приїжджаючи знову в заклад
Бачиш як вони змінюються і от власне
завдяки тому що вони змінюються завдяки
тому от ми знаємо що це одна із таких та
навичок яка на сьогодні є надзвичайно
затребуваною та тобто не боятися зміни
бути готовими до змін от система
професійно-технічної освіти А можливо і
не зовсім готова до змін Давайте будемо
об'єктивно але точно нічого не боїться і
точно готовий йти вперед і на сьогодні
варто теж зауважити що багато хто
змінює фокус Тобто ми зосереджуємо свою
увагу не тільки на підготовці молоді до
професійної діяльності а повертаємося ще
й до того щоб допомогти дорослим які
втратили роботу або дорослим які
розуміють
трансформації на ринку праці зміни в
професіях дивіться якісь професії
взагалі відмирають на сьогодні А можливо
хтось і ну найближчим часом там
Почтальон та тобто поштари Хто в нас є
в Естонії вже цю роботу виконують роботи
і тут питання Що Що буде завтра і які
професії зміниться Але хтось має
керувати цими роботами Хтось має їх
ремонтувати тобто цей фокус він постійно
змінюється і тут мені здається ми
великий крок робили зробили разом з
програмою В тій частині що спробували
різні підходи до розроблення освітніх
стандартів в нас нарешті з'явилася
система професійних стандартів яка
зростає щодня і кількість поданих заявок
на розроблення професійних стандартів і
кількість затверджених значно
збільшується а це означає що система
стає наближеною до ринку праці
і Мабуть це те найголовніше до чого ми
прагнемо всі щоб зміст освіти не був
відірваним Не був там з космосу а саме
відповідав сьогоднішнім е-е
потребам і і ми могли активно
змінюватись до прикладу ми переглядаємо
освітні стандарти один раз на 5 років чи
цього достатньо чи потрібно раніше в
минулому році затвердили стандарт сапера
цього року розуміємо що сапер
розмінування там чи супер замінування
вже потребує перегляду тому що з'явилося
нове обладнання ним треба вміти
користуватись ми розуміємо що термін
підготовки цих фахівців Сьогодні має
бути точно скорочений і ми не можемо
дозволити собі більше це означає що
цього року ми повертаємося до цього
стандарту і переглядаємо знову і не
чекаємо ще 4 роки тому власне оця
гнучкість системи це те до чого ми
говорили як і це було До речі одна із
цілей завдань програми забезпечити цю
гнучкість як на національному рівні так
і на регіональному рівні звичайно ще
немає ідеалу нам є до чого прагнути і ми
знаємо свої слабкі місця але те що зміни
відбулися І ці зміни помітні це вже
напевно 100% Дякую
продовжимо також з вами В мене зразу
виникає багато запитань але я Хотіла
задати запитання пані міні-спік
English nows of ifinite
для перекладачі е-е все він так і багато
звичайнос будемо хочу запитати про зміни
який
досвід Фінляндії ви могли би
запропонувати до використання в Україні
тому що ми знаємо що фіцька система у
світі вважається однією з найкращих у
світі і
і
яке яку
професійно-технічну освіту Ми ви могли
би за пропонувати як краще досвід
Всіх вітаю
я рада
розповісти вам про фінські підхід хоча
це запитання можна було би поставити
Ірині яка нещодавно відвідала Фінляндію
і було би цікаво дізнатися як вона це
побачила
що можна запровадити в Україні Ірина
почала говорити про зміни
нещодавно ми з паном а-а ще з j-z
говорили про гнучкість і це є наш підхід
це не типово
фінські підхід але це гнучкість це той
підхід який дуже корисний і в Фінляндії
в Україні будь-якій країні а ми не
можемо передбачити майбутнє Ми не можемо
поглянути в майбутнє
коли я в лютому
двадцятого приїхала в Україну я не могла
навіть уявити що може зробити Кові де в
Фінляндії в Україні а коли ми приїхали
Ми ніколи не могли уявити що Росія таке
дійсно розпочне війну хоча ми могли би
про це здогадуватися але ми в це не
вірила Ми
майбутнє має багато сценаріїв і нам
потрібно така система як буде реагувати
дуже швидко і що ми
застосовуємо для цього
ми розуміємо що маємо служити окремим
людям і суспільство одночасно що означає
гнучкість має різні форми
щоб ми могли
задовольнити Потреби Потреби окремих
категорій учнів тих хто навчається у нас
можуть бути
учні Скажімо так студенти зі
спеціальними потребами і мені здається І
в Україні таких буде багато
нам треба
передбачати таку повну модульність
навчання щоб задовольнити індивідуальні
потреби у Фінляндії один раз на рік
будь-яка молода людина може податися на
будь-який
[музика]
професійно-технічний курс а
і тут вступає в гру таке що людина може
не здогадуватися що саме їй потрібно на
що саме варто подати і останнє що я хочу
сказати що
професійно-технічна освіта в
Фінляндії пропонує освіту не тільки для
молоді але і для людей
дуже дорослих старшого покоління Ми
думаємо постійно як нам задовольнити
потреби і молоді і більш зрілох
поколінь одночасно в найбільш ефективний
спосіб Дякую Можливо будуть пізніше
запитання і мені здається що така
важлива річ як щось життєстійкість цієї
системи та яка буде базуватися на
гнучкості це я дуже важлива річ Дякую
мені на за цей за цей напрям для
подальшої нашої розмови
Ну і в контексті гнучкості В мене є
запитання до пана Юрія
гнучкість і стандарти як ці речі
поєднуються з точки зору якщо ми
говоримо про
і про те що дав проект у фоскілс
наприклад для того щоб можливо підійти
по іншому до розробки стандартів
професій до зміни підходу так що те що
говорила Ірина там частіше переглядати
бути гнучкі ми мати можливість реагувати
на потребу що скажете
осіб Доброго дня
Я хочу сказати що результат Ось цього
проекту є
29 кваліфікаційних центрів
128 професійних кваліфікацій які можна
присвоїти в цих кваліфікаційних центрів
1364 професійній кваліфікації які вже
присвоєні в цьому кваліфікаційному
центрі
230 експертів які здійснюють акредитації
кваліфікаційних центрів
270 професійних стандартів і 178 заявок
на нові професійні стандарти і 25 на
перегляд старих діючих професійних
стандартів це про гнучкість про
адаптивність і про необхідність
реальним викликам часу
ми говоримо про те які нам сьогодні
потрібні професії потрібні нам
кваліфікації Я два тижні тому був у
Брюсселі на з'їзді національних
координаторів європейського року навичок
Я їм зазначив Шановні колеги в
Європейському Союзі 33 країни були
присутні що у
травні місяці тільки на місто Київ було
здійснено 20 Атак
під час атак було використано 120 ракет
200 шахедів тому в першу чергу нам
важливі навички і кваліфікації які
сьогодні рятують життя
Очевидно це пріоритет і зброєні сили
України з цим справляються і тут
гнучкість також про це треба говорити
тому що Національне агентство в
кваліфікації здійснило перевірку вже 8
професійних стандартів військових яких
розробили Національна гвардія І зараз
заявки і увага до цього питання є
наступне питання ми розуміємо що збройні
сили - це перший рубіж а другий рубіж -
це економіка без економіки збройні сили
не зможуть наші воювати і тому
відновлення Української Держави немає
починатися після завершення війни воно
має починатися зараз тому Національне
агентство кваліфікації здійснює постійно
процедуру навчання і 11
11 липня ми починаємо черговий етап
навчання розробників професійних
стандартів що таке професійні стандарти
Мені здається всі прекрасно це розуміють
але я хочу ще раз на тому наголосити що
не буде цвісти квітка професійної
технічної освіти яка потрібна Україні
якщо не буде якісною вимоги до тої
освіти а якісною вимогою є зерно яке ми
будемо сіяти А це зерно має закласти
ринок економіка вимогу до того фахівця
який він завтра потрібен ми говоримо про
професії також треба говорити про
глибину професії тому що Дмитро
Завгородній
Він сказав що він Нова людина не нова
він людина тому що коли він працював у
міністерстві цифрової трансформації він
з командою Валерію заклав вимогу у всі
професійні стандарти наявність цифрової
компетентності що це означає що всі
професійні стандарти будуть містити цю
компонент другий момент якщо ми говоримо
про флексибилиті про вимоги про
інтеграцію в єу в юрпінь Юніон то ми
маємо говорити про те що ми маємо
відповідати адженді Європейського Союзу
якщо ми говоримо про Green Skills то всі
будівельні професії на які розробляється
професійні стандарти мають містити
енергоефективну компоненту тоді ми
будемо якісно вставляти вікна якісно
будувати будинки якісно їх проектувати
ми маємо реагувати на ринок сьогодні
ринок має диктувати вся освіта має йти
до ринку питатися Як це зробити і цим
інструментом є агентство в частині
розроблення професійних стандартів
другий момент що стосується швидкості
швидкості виходу людей на ринок праці це
кваліфікаційний центр кваліфікаційний
центр не навчає
кваліфікаційний центр швидко реагує якщо
людина
навчилася неформально і формально і
навіть формально Але у неї немає
професійної кваліфікації вона може
прийти в цей кваліфікаційний центр і
присвоїти відповідно до вимог
професійного стандарту що робить
кваліфікаційний центр мірі є
спроможність людини по її знання вмінням
і навичким виконувати цей професійний
стандарт А професійний стандарт формує
ринок відповідно якщо він завтра
змінився людина має адаптуватися тому що
якби ми як це тими самими професіями
їхали то ми не використовували сьогодні
навіть би двигун внутрішнього згорання
Ми би їздили далі на конях Ну Ось така
моя відповідь на ваше запитання
Дякую Дякую
Ну мені здається що це важливо мені
зразу знаєте виникає ми зараз говоримо
про які професії ну тобто але ми зараз
до цього до цього дійдемо або ви мені
скажете Да давайте будемо на конях Ми
також їздимо на конях але це це ми
розуміємо що війна ставить перед нами
колосальні виклики і конвенційна
компонента в війні - це за моєю
особистою оцінкою є приблизно
50-55%. очевидно що інша компонента це є
інформаційна війна інформаційна безпека
це є важлива компонента безпеки
Української держави тому наприклад
державна служба спеціального зв'язку із
захисту інформації розробила уже 6
професійних стандартів які відповідають
там які забезпечують безпеку мережі які
забезпечують безпеку інформації
збереження і інше зараз вони розробляють
ще 14 професійних стандартів і ці
професій стандарти будуть вимогою для
освітньої програми і освітнього
стандарту якщо він адміністратор мереж і
систем то це не той самий адміністратор
мереж і систем які був 10 років тому чи
20 Тому що з особистого досвіду скажу що
наприклад Збройних Силах України 20
років тому підрозділ зв'язку це була
колона довжиною 8 км а зараз це
маленький мікроавтобус який вміщається
всі
радіостанції які необхідні для
забезпечення зв'язком відповідного
підрозділу тому вимога до професії
змінюється але актуальність стоїть зараз
така наступна Я підтримую колегу з
Міністерства освіти яка говорила про
електрогазозварників таких
кваліфікаційних центрів ми акредитували
велику кількість і акредитували зверніть
увагу у
обласних центрах які прифронтовій зоні
це Запорізька область це Дніпро місто
Дніпро
Харківська область це важливо якщо люди
щось там роблять якщо люди відкривають
кваліфікаційний центр значить вони щось
планують значить ці люди вірять в те що
Україна буде і так буде тому тут Ця
інформація є вся відкрита Національне
агентство кваліфікації є максимально
прозорою організацією як акваріум будь
ласка вся інформація публікується
постійно на наших електронних ресурсах
всі це бачать лайкають поширюють
іовелкам Дякую головне та щоб це І
дальше країні допомагали це до речі дуже
те що ви сказали про
прифронтові області які дуже сильно
включені ми коли реалізовували проект
освітній виднокурс по навчанню ми вчили
в онлайні більше 200 людей зі всієї
України представників і закладів
професійно-технічної освіти методичних
центрів то в нас були люди з Херсона
пам'ятаєте у нас Тобто це було ще під
окупацією вона включа кожного разу ми
раз в тиждень зустрічалися тому що вона
була з закладу і хотіла навчатися тому
що впевнена була в тому що буде
звільнено Херсон і так дальше це завжди
дуже сильно нахало всіх людей які
долучалися в неї то зв'язок пропадав і
так дальше пані Наталя пам'ятаю її
Передаю привіт можливо нас Слухай от це
дуже важливо ну тобто все те що ми
робимо робимо для людей і для студентів
і для майбутнього тому дуже дякую пане
Юрію що ви е-е цим поділилися тепер
Давайте поговоримо про досягнення завжди
при виклики про контекст цікаво але
хотілося би про досягнення давайте собі
відтворимо і у фоскіз чотири роки так
3,5 роки реалізовувався проект з чотири
багато було зроблено зі своєю
перспективи кожного якісь Три речі які
би ви відмітили щоб було важливими які
або змінили або за стартували якісь
певний процес який вже не змінити він
тільки буде рухатися в правильному
Давайте почнемо з Ірини І так поколи я
тоді закінчимо пане Павлом Ой ну Мені
насправді дуже складно говорити про три
речі чотири роки тому назад Було дуже
страшно було дуже страшно брати
відповідальність не тільки там за проект
а а взагалі за реформу
професійно-технічної освіти тому що а-а
завдання проекту цілкови то співпадали з
тим що ми запланували собі як реформу
професійної освіти разом з Європейським
фондом освіти і ми це зрозуміли тільки
тоді коли почали виконувати ці завдання
і зрозуміли наскільки це не просто і не
складно але мабуть знову ж таки це наша
особлива риса не боятися А робити і в
процесі роботи вже тоді зрозуміти
виклики і на них активно реагувати для
мене мабуть найбільше те що мені Ну як
знаєте те що я можу вважати подарунком
собі на день народження от от для мене
це що дійсно професійно-технічна освіта
обличчя професійно-технічної освіти
змінилося змінилося Люди ми можемо вже
зараз не боїмося якщо ми на перший
відеоролик не могли знайти учня чи
ученицю Які би змогли спокійно собі
взяти і записатись там боялися камери
боялися щось говорити а в процесі
знімаючи ролики про пряночки з
валентинками у вигляді валентинок Ми
бачили як діти
прагнуть як вони змінюються як вони
хочуть бути активними учасниками так
само активними учасниками стали звичайні
викладачі змінюються наші керівники
закладів які десь підгледіли зарубіжний
досвід хтось поїхав у Фінляндію хтось в
Естонію і вже розуміючи що все можливо
та і все в наших руках вони почали
змінюватись Це мабуть от оце нове
обличчя про в техосвіти
Це перша риса друга риса - Це мабуть теж
зміна підходів І
знаєте найулюбленіше що в Великих
системах є у нас завжди так було і ми
завжди так робили От коли ми починали
тільки зміни часто зустрічалися з такою
відповіддю А давайте зробимо Тан у нашу
в нас і так добре працює і в нас ось
було і воно ж було непогано навіщо щось
змінювати і ось тут мабуть дитина в
кожному з нас яка прагне до пізнання там
мені часто закидають А що спільного між
наукою і про втехом то насправді дуже
багато не головна риса науковця - це
прагне прагнення до пізнання нового І
власне тут Ми якраз з профтехівцями
крокуємо нога в ногу і
мабуть третє щоб можна було сказати це
те як нас цей проект згуртував з одного
боку нам початку були певні Павло
Кузьмович пам'ятає коли ми відбирали і
Петро Миколайович Також тут пам'ятаю
коли вибирали області було багато
ображених і в мене весь час був такий
посил до менеджменту проекту що давайте
більше залучати інші області ми це
можемо зробити не завжди потрібні гроші
для цього ми можемо охоплювати ширше от
сьогодні коли Олексій презентував до
прикладу там цифри охоплені і оцей ковід
і насправді війна бо воно масштабна вона
показали що дійсно ми можемо діяти в
набагато ширших масштабах і ось оця
команда яка
з'явилася нова команда про втехівців
от Це мабуть найбільше досягнення для
мене я зараз не кажу про цифри не кажу
про кількість заходів кількість
учасників а от Саме ці зміни які є
системними дякую
пані
ніноперспектів
з вашої точки зору які три такі можливо
історії успіху від форс-хеллс
я гадаю більше ніж три їх але безумовно
мені доведеться вибрати щось умисне
і хочу згадати те до чого долучилися
саме фінський експерти вибачаюся перед
німецькими польськими естонськими
колегами але мушу говорити про фільми І
хочу сказати що дуже важливо завжди
пам'ятати про роль викладачів вчителів і
керівників закладів коли ми впроваджуємо
будь-яку реформу у повсякденній освіті
і керівництво адміністрація закладів
вони дійсно були залучені в ході проекту
бо проект це розумів і це було важливо
Це відіграло провідну роль бо вони саме
адміністратори виступали як Агенти змін
бо вони займалися повсякденністю оцієї
якісною світ
Ми займалися питаннями
компетенції зокрема для
адміністративного складу для викладачів
в ході реформи і ці компетенції почали
себе коучи співпрацю
з роботодавцями з реальними компаніями
управління навичками
і скринінг
і я вважаю що це дуже важливо Я думаю що
нам варто задатися запитанням як система
профтехосвіти Може дійсно
спричинити сприяти сталому розвитку
цілої країни для цього ми маємо ділитися
нашими знаннями практиками і з нашими
учнями які стануть в подальшому
фахівцями у своїй сфері колега вже
колеги вже згадували
є дуже багато пов'язаних з цим питанням
наприклад
яке матеріали використовувати для
будівництва новинки чи для
відновлення існуючого житла яке ми є
вуглецевий слід нових матеріалів чому це
важливо
яке ми є альтернативні джерела енергії
осі такі зелені питання дуже важливі чи
як
змінити хімічний наслідки салонів краси
для довкілля це все працює на
позеленішання суспільства на більш
зелену з профтехосвіту І дійсно тут
великою великою бачу роль викладачів в
адміністраторів вони дійсно здатні
донести це
другий момент який хочеться згадати Це
розробка навчальних програм і стандартів
ми всі хочемо якісною освіти хочемо щоб
стандарти були навчальні програми
сучасні якщо цього не відбувається то
дуже важко вдається реагувати на потреби
суспільства Тим більше що вони постійно
змінюються
і Ірина робочої сили потребує
різних речей
і завжди треба намагатися відповідати
цим потребам
і фінський експерт із допомагали з
розробкою 20 стандартів
освітніх і 20 навчальних програм Я
розумію що це мало але ми робили це
знаєте з метою
навчити українських колег
виконувати цей проект процес
робити це краще щоб це відповідала
потребам і ринку праці і суспільства Я
розумію що це настільки питання
кількості розробленого Скільки
опануванню цього процесу для того щоб
підвищити посилити потенціал тих в
Україні хто цим далі буде займатися
Тобто це розбудова потенціалу така
[музика]
також чотири профілі компетенції були
розроблені
враховуючи зокрема і поточне воєнний
стан і потреби відновлення це
стосувалося зокрема і будівництво малих
об’єктів житлових
реконструкції житла
реконструкція об'єктів інфраструктури
роботи з поводження з відходами
відновлення довкілля це Ті теми які На
жаль через війну яка тільки шкода
завдала Україна будуть дедалі тільки
збільшувати свою актуальність
також Ми займалися питаннями надання
підтримки тим хто зазнав травм фізичних
психологічних під час війни
це дуже важливо це дуже важливе
складовою є будь-якою
системи освіти і будь-кого рівня освіти
Ми також розробили 20 скорочених
онлайн-курсів
вони вже були розроблені після початку
війни і ми робили це з розумінням що
треба щось зробити цьому напрямку і
зробити це треба так щоб люди могли
легко мати доступ деінде в Україні з
інших країн
і
кількість
учасників які зареєструвалися
також говорить про те що людям це було
потрібно до кінця березня
більше 19 тисяч реєстрацій на це курси
ми мали
і
більш
12,5 тисяч сертифікатів було видано
і я думаю що це теж можна назвати
досягненнями Я думаю що це ті досягнення
які ми
спільними зусиллями зробили і я
сподіваюся що це далі буде працювати на
користь реформи попри будь-які викликів
це дуже гарна річ
що ви скажете які три ви вважаєте
основні досягнення проекту
Справа в тому що
Національне агентство кваліфікації не
пам'ятає свого існування без проекту UFO
Skills
тому що ми створилися В 19-му році в
кінці року 12 листопада ми почали
працювати як організація юридична А
через два місяці почався ковід потім
війна тому тут якісь краш-тест під час
всієї діяльності агенції але тут треба
віддати належне І подякувати проекту UFO
Skills тому що насправді Наші перші
комунікації відбувалися на принципах
розуміння формування систем кваліфікації
у Європейському Союзі і якщо ми хочемо
бути в Європейському Союзі А ми цього
хочемо то ми не можемо зробити по-своєму
ми маємо зробити симила таку саму таку
саму систему схожу яка була б вона
адаптована і в до вимог Європейського
Союзу ми маємо розмовляти однією мовою в
системі кваліфікації з нашими
європейськими партнерами Тому перше що
ми почали ми набувати досвід як це все
працює
ми мали декілька візитів в Європейські
країни ми мали візити в конкретні
кваліфікаційні центри комунікації з
міністерствами освіти з регіональними
центрами освіти і інше інше Це
детальніше можемо вже за кавою розповім
Але що ми важливе зробили ми весь Всі
кращі практики які є в Європейському
Союзі або принаймні ті які ми могли
здобути ми імплементували усі
нормативно-правові акти які сьогодні
регулюють діяльність національного
агентства кваліфікації все що ми могли
ми туди зробили це перший момент За який
я дякую проекту ufskills
другий момент який стосується
лібералізації багатьох процесів і тут
треба віддати належне що
український парламент змінив правила гри
на
ланцюжку організації людського капіталу
проект закону співавтор якого зараз
сидить у залі це Ольга Коваль набрав
конституційну більшість цей закон змінив
правила гри формування професійних
стандартів чому це важливо тому що не
може визначати ні голова наку ні
директор Департаменту чи навіть
заступник Міністра який має бути
зварювальник чи який має бути Токар І ми
про це всі домовились всі середовища
домовились про те що це має визначати
професійне середовище а функція держави
тільки контроль форми контроль процедури
і максимальна лібералізація і сприяння і
Це дало можливість результату про який
на початку зачитав це заклади про в тих
освіти сьогодні масово пишуть заявки в
НАК Ми хочемо крім формальної компоненти
робити ще й неформально Давайте зробимо
у нас кваліфікаційний центр і на базі
закладів профтехосвіти сьогодні
створюється велика кількість
кваліфікаційних центрів і в тому числі у
прифронтовій зоні третій момент який
важливий що зробила українська держава
на початку створення національного
агентства кваліфікації вона змінила
законодавство і привела у відповідність
кількість рівнів рамки кваліфікації
європейським вимогам
це означає що це фундаментальні зміни це
фундаментальні принципи розуміння один
одного це так само як важити зерно Чи
масло кілограмами Чи це так само як
міряти відстань метрами це та сама рамка
кваліфікації якою ми міряємо
кваліфікацію людини того чи Індії чи
іншої професії то тут ми зробили поступ
і ми як українська держава здійснили
порівняння національної рамки і
європейської рамки кваліфікації
наступний етап - це третій пункт але
будь ласка дозвольте я його розвину
бо в мене також добре з математикою у
нас по 12 з половиною хвилин на
виступаючу так і тут зараз ми створили
ncp це передбачено законодавством
Європейського Союзу ми створили
національний координаційний центр
європейської рамки кваліфікації і у нас
завтра одна із робочих зустрічей з
європейською комісією частині Того Коли
ми почнемо здійснювати співставлення
нашої рамки європейської рамки
кваліфікації От коли ми завершимо
співставлення цієї рамки то ми відкриємо
нові двері які дадуть нам можливість
розуміти і тому тут треба важливо
сказати що навіть в робочу групу з
порівняння національної рамки
кваліфікацій входив наш великий друг
Роман Горовий
і і цей звіт підписаний європейською
комісією міністерством освіти України Це
є третій результат За який я пишаюся
спільною нашою співпраці тому я
сподіваюсь що проект Skills for Recovery
буде не менш
важливий а навіть більш актуальніші
враховуючи виклики часу і глибину
розуміння нас
як країну і нами як Європейського Союзу
дякую дякую вам дякую
Добре дякую насправді це проект надав
як свою чергу хочу сказати найбільше
вкладення
в наших педагогічних працівників
закладів професійно-технічної освіти
як багато наразі говорять що людський
капітал вкладеш в нього
відбудуєш всю країну відбудуєш Все я
можу сказати що насправді Протягом цього
проекту Протягом цього цих чотирьох
років педагогічні працівники закладів
освіти мали змогу багато чому навчитися
мали змогу підвищити рівень своїх
навичок рівень своїх
компетентностей які вони могли вже
подати
в закладах освіти безпосередньо
здобувачам освіти
по-друге на рівні державної служби
зайнятості можу сказати що насправді в
рамках цього проекту ми змогли досягти
оцієїсь енергії під час дослідження
ринків праці які ми проводили і внести
зміни безпосередньо в ті законодавчі
документи які потребували цих змін це як
і перелік професій з надання вау-чарів
ми інформацію основну витримку для зміни
цього переліку брали з Дослідження які
проводили безпосередньо з роботодавцями
потреба роботодавців Ну і насамперед в
нас Державна служба зайнятості також має
центри професійно-технічної освіти я
можу сказати що так в рамках даного
проекту одного з його компонентів - це
інтеграція внутрішнього приміщених осіб
ми мали змогу модернізувати заклади свою
професійно-технічної освіти і насправді
я кажу пан Юрій дуже
такий гарний момент щодо кваліфікаційних
центрів кваліфікаційні центри Наразі це
є дуже важливою точкою Чому навіть
інколи не тільки тоді коли особа має
безпосередньо ті навички ті професійні
вміння а зараз наразі В даний проміжок
часу в нас є багато внутрішнього
приміщених осіб які втратили свої
документи про освіту і насправді такі
центри надають можливості
особам швидко дуже швидко отримати
документ тому що наше законодавство під
час працевлаштування потребує цієї
офіційної
дантування офіційного документу Що
насправді є навчався я маю такі навички
і це є Ну такими трьома основними як на
мене аспектами які ми отримали під час
провадження даного проекту дякую Дуже
дякую вам велике
пане Павла що ви скажете ви як я вже вас
коли анонсувала тобто спочатку ви були в
проекті Так коли б ви в міністерстві
готували проект і ні все здається все
працює так проект готували проект
за те що запросили знаєте хоч воно
називається фінальне але тут кожен
українець практично знає цю фразу Ліни
Костенко і коли вже фініш - це по суті
старт Я дивлюся на пані віру в грибак з
якою ми починали цей проект і тоді коли
він був дуже багато було зроблено дуже
багато було дискусій ми тоді зрозуміли
Міністерство Ми зрозуміли таку річ що
перше чим відрізняється
[музика]
загальна середня освіта від професійної
що там є роботодавець школи немає
роботодавця тому що хтось на середню
освіту ти тут маєш ще одного партнера
який роботодавець Треба з ним правильно
працювати правильно готувати і давати
правильно як це було перше друге що
присійного світу дає не тільки систему
освіти але так само дають роботодавці і
якщо дивитися кого скільки-то скажімо Ну
може як два до одного буде десь буде
така така професія і третє теж ми
розуміли що не треба говорити тільки про
освіту учнів а треба говорити про освіту
дорослих і зараз чим раз тим більше ми
маємо звертати свою увагу на ці короткі
програми які не повинні забезпечити
повну загальну середню освіту бо ті люди
вже цю загальну середню мають а деколи
Ви що мають освіту і більшість випадків
Вони мають вищу освіту і тоді їх треба
долучити це є перше друге
ми тоді знаєте як кажуть дерованому
Коневі в зуби не дивляться і було ті 54
млн але ми так казали каже пані Віра
Перетворіть ви там ближче до Європи е-е
переговоріть Грузія дістало 30 ну Грузії
не можна рівняти з Україною все-таки тут
розміри більше і оця фраза Ліни Костенко
це старт це посил до того що треба
продовжувати і робити тому що викликів
перед Україною зараз є набагато більше
відбудови економіки відбудови і держави
після цього агресора те що те що було те
що було зроблено це є перше друга бо
мені не дали слово перший раз то я собі
візьму сам
Як казав 12 хвилин я жартую буде коротше
буде короче е друга теза є та
роботодавця Є але треба розуміти що у
нас Якщо ми подивимося на учнів
професійної освіти наших закладів це є
е-е як два до одного тобто дві частини -
це є випускники дев'ятого класу і одна
частина цієї випускники з повної
загальної середньої освіти і коли ти
говориш про випускників після дев'ятого
класу які не мають повну загальної
середньої освіти то треба розуміти що
вони мають право вибору бо є
конституційне право кожної особи вибрати
собі оце профільне навчання і вибір цієї
професії тобто з одного боку Я завжди
там розглядати в цій системі координат
таке подвійні перше конституційне право
мати і вибору і друге а які потрібно
Українки праці і це має коригувати все
точно має бути І в чому проект доклався
це те що має бути якість що якщо ми
готуємо то ми вже готуємо не просто
робітника ми завжди казали в нас
робітників багато але
висококваліфікованих на жаль завжди є
дефіцит і треба було їх шукати
і остання спогади тоді переходить на
ваше питання Я пам'ятаю що його так е-е
коли ми говорили про проект колеги ми
завжди ну міністр Ліля Гриневич з якої я
мав приємністю честь працювати
е-е Ми дуже хотіли збільшувати цей так
званий харткомпонент тобто те що
лишається бо ми розуміли що совкомпонент
він важливий бо все вирішують насправді
люди але є така річ е-е що якщо ти
найкраще навчив людей і чим ти кращий
навчиш людину яка працює освіти є
великий шанси що на цю сферу покине І
піде в інші сфери в силу заробітної
плати Тобто ми виймалося якщо ти сильно
розвиваєш компетентності ти працюєш
робиш розвинув людину Я навіть дивлюся
По керівництву оскільки є в проектах
Зараз людей які працювали в міністерстві
і які працювали в департаменті освіти
Львівської обласної організації теж
заступниця Олега Володимировича зараз
перейшла працювати в юнісе і так далі
тобто з тими м'якими навичками вони
важливі але ти не можеш гарантувати що
ці люди в яких ти вкладаєш вони лишиться
в цій системі освіти оцей хардкомпонент
ці наші
позитивні практики е центру досконалості
ну наразі проект закінчився але ми цих
центрів досконалості ще не бачимо тобто
але віримо що Наші улюблені Кая в дубль
в е-е що на шкаф виконані ті обіцянки бо
Завжди з ними було тяжко на початках
проекту я дивлюся в реалізації теж є але
ми розуміємо що йде війна що поки йде
поки немає перемоги це тяжко речі робити
тепер тепер відповідь на ваше питання
Минулого тижня у Львові відбувся великий
освітній фестиваль в якому присутні
Міністр освіти Оксан Лісовий і Ксеню
сивий чітко сказав бо день перед тим це
було в четвер виступав міністр один
перед тим Ну ви потім працювали в офісі
працювали з президентом і говорили про
Я тут не розкраю сказати правда Дмитре
ви там були я знаю ви більше знаєте але
те що сказав міністр публічно я той
відтворюю е-е було чітко сказано що
зараз для країни пріоритет номер один це
є оборона це є збройні сили України все
що пов'язано з перемогою із безпекою а
пріоритет номер два - це і освіта бо
неможливо відбудувати економіку про яку
я говорю пан Юрій чесно с- цілком слушно
якщо людський капітал не буде розвинений
тобто якщо не буде кому це робити тобто
тому тут безумовно цей ця нас має це
надихати і друге що міністр важливо
сказав що Україна я працівником
погоджуюсь
сталось суб'єктом розумієте не об'єктом
а суб'єкту суб'єктність України через цю
біду ніколи не була така високою як є як
є зараз тому є дуже багато можливостей і
їм треба користуватися що ж зробили в
проекті перше е-е той компонент скажімо
за кіно яке відповідав це спочатку ми
говорили про регіональні ради розвитку
професійної освіти я би так сказав
боротьба з совдепією і перехід до
громадянського суспільства з вертикалі
на горизонтальні рівні коли є
комунікація коли і діалог цього діалогу
бракує система освіти вона любить бути
замкнена ти набрав ти навчив все навчив
що зробив Ну то вже таке тут восени
набрати Ну і ви і випустити тобто от
проект от показував і Багато роботи було
зроблено для того що не є питання просто
випустити є питання кого випустити з
якими компетентностями ну і ще важливо
от те що ви кажете інтерв'ю не брали ну
питання тому що наша система вона трохи
зашугує людей і тому є нова українська
школа яка їх розкриває робить вільними
які дає можливість говорити і цей
елемент е-е відкритості е-е вірив в себе
якось певною впевненості має переходити
і цей компетенція яких він має
переходити в систему професійного світу
тому ми оці діалоги 18 регіонів коли
керівник Ну ще позитивно що система
против освіти мала керівника який от
зараз Ірина вже при чотирьох міністрів
працює так е-е четвертий міністр е-е це
так бюрократія люблять рахувати при
скількох міністрах працювали але цей
страшенно позитивне тому що І завдяки
проекту наша е-е смішна фахова
передвищення є така галузь Я думаю
депутати щось зроблять з нею найближчий
час ця фахова передвищення вона вже каже
слухайте Та ми хочемо йти в професійну
освіту розумієте та там робиться там
проекти там щось відбувається А кому ми
потрібні кажу правильно чого ж ви звідти
пішли з само Спочатку ви там мали бути і
тоді би Ірина сумі керувала і вами і
тоді би а дмитроби керував Іриною сумік
і тоді би Всі ці речі дуже добре дуже
добре відбувалися А ти б це є важливі
речі і а з таких конкретно можна і три
речі
та
дистанційна освіта важлива
профорієнтація І імічна що робили бо це
є проблема І звичайно це ще по
кваліфікації це велике дякую дякую
можна дуже важливим те що в нас сьогодні
не зважаючи на те що захист захід
називається фінальний насправді ми точно
знаємо Принаймні з пані вірою що її
форс-кіл ще не закінчили свою роботу в
Україні і от Якраз сьогодні ми
ставимо таку я сподіваюся кому не крапку
в тому що стосується першого і другого
компоненту тобто розвитку
soft-навичок а от третій ще
продовжується працювати я думаю Павло
Кузь мови чому у вас таке здивуємо
то мабуть не в нас Я так думаю Та я
думаю що він дійсно скільки тут Вся
Україна пані Віра та я думаю що ви краще
скажете про те що нас чекають
там включено будь ласка включено
включено нічого не рухайте говоріть
просто я би хотіла відповісти
Павлу кузьмовичу дійсно
Ми дуже багато працювали над дизайном
цього проекту і я пам'ятаю
наполегливість Міністерства стосовно
компоненту
розвитку інфраструктури
тим не менше Я хочу сказати що величезне
надбання цього проекту та зміцнення
інституційної спроможності ту команду
яку Ми наразі маємо це настільки
очевидно що це дуже сильна дуже потужна
українська команда яка була створена в
тому числі і завдяки
нашому проекту
повертаючись до
компоненту інфраструктури
Давайте ми не будемо забувати що 21
мільйон який виділив Європейський союз
підтриманий 20 на сьогодні мільйонами
уряду Німеччини які прийдуть трошечки
пізніше і можливо і можливо Це
врешті-решт правильно тому що війна все
одно не дала нам реалізувати цей
компонент і
європейські інвестиційний банк своїм
кредитом 58 мільйонів саме на створення
центрів професійної досконалості
приєднався також завдяки програмі
Європейського союзу в програмі яка
підтримана іншими донорами Німеччиною
фінляндією Польщею
Естонію в імплементації саме тому
європейські Інвестиційний банк
приєднався тобто в принципі у нас досить
потужні масові ресурси і на
інфраструктурний компонент але ви
правильно сказали що без людей
жодна інфраструктура саме найкращий
Центр професійної досконалості працювати
не буде і тому я дуже вірю в те що
наш капітал саме капітал Human Capital
він все-таки є основою і як сказав
нещодавно
віце-президент
єврокомісії перебуваючи з візитом Це
дійсно кров це блад
дімокристі and Blood for економіки Дякую
Дякую вам велике
Я хотіла би щоб ви мені підтвердили що в
місті Києві є тривога тому що в
Київській області точно
прямо в цю секунду бачите
Ми якраз завершуємо я буквально хочу
попросити одне слово і ми йдемо можна
одне слово по одному слову майбутнє
майбутнє одне
майбутнє професійно-технічної освіти
одне слово тому що нам треба йти в
укриття
для мене професійна освіта це власне
розвиток талантів і я точно скажу що
воно буде І ми тут переможемо Дякую в
oned About the future only one on the
future я
Надія
і сподівання на людей із суспільством
майбутнім
Так пане Юрію прям вкрали
я скажу
профтехосвіту насправді це майбутнє
дякую
світу яка буде сміло конкурувати з вищою
освітою Супер дякую на цій ноті Та
давайте поаплодуємо
[оплески]
сподіваюся що вам було цікаво корисно і
ви отримали також знову ще один заряд Я
можу дуже швидко сказати про те що зараз
ми мусимо йти заряд в хорошому сенсі
цього слова зараз маємо йти на в укриття
тому що в нас повітряна тривога немає
немає А що ж ви мене так цей немає Тоді
ми можемо продовжувати спілкуватися
тільки в Київській області
повітряна тривога Я просто переживаю що
вона зараз до Києва
дійде Я хочу вам величезну Дякую
подякувати в нас на жаль немає вже часу
подякувати вам за розмову Мені здається
що в нас вийшло дуже активно і цікаво в
мене ще було до вас дуже-дуже забагато
запитань Сподіваюся під час кави ми
можемо про них поспілкуватися Дякую
можете займати помаленьку місця А я
хотіла вам зробити пару оголошень поки в
нас є можливість поки ми знаходимося у
безпеці у нас протягом години буде обід
з 12-ї до
13-ї години о 13:00 у нас буде і о 13:14
Дві паралельні сесії у вас насправді це
все написано в програмі але я вам це
озвучу зараз секунду
о 13:00 буде Дві паралельні сесії перша
сесія вона буде знаходитися проводитися
В цьому залі і це буде сесія Як
змінилася система професійної освіти на
регіональному рівні якраз модератором
буде Павло хобзей якого ви тільки що
чули це національний експерт його
фоскілс це буде знаходитися тут і буде
друга паралельна сесія про співпрацю
системи професійної освіти та ринку
праці модератором буде Олексій Олексюк і
ця Сесія буде відбуватися на на вищому
поверсі на поверсі М2 для того що тут
обиратися треба зайти ліфт і в ліфтом
піднятися тому що сходів немає щоби
піднятися на цей поверх М2 ви протягом
обіду подумайте яка вам сесія цікавіша і
прошу вас можливо Якщо ви приїхали
декілька людей з одного закладу то
декілька людей йде на цю на цю сесію
інша кількість людей йде Натуся а потім
в перер поміняєтеся досвідом і розкажете
одна одному Про що ви почули так щоби у
нас була однакова кількість людей у двох
залах Якщо вам треба будуть навушники
Але мені здається А тобі що для
англомовних спікерів то беріть навушники
з собою і важливо під час обіду залишити
всі навушники на столах тобто нічого не
беріть тому що навушники Це важливо щоб
Вони залишилися і потім ми за вами не
бігали Дивіться і о 14:10 Тобто там буде
перерва тому що ви зможете подумати яка
яке Вам наступні сесії цікаві У 14
годині буде ще дві сесії також
паралельні В цьому залі буде проходити
сесія digitalliзація та її роль у
розвитку професійної освіти будемо
дарувати пані Ганна сухоцька
і буде також четверта сесія це
забезпечення якості підготовки у системі
професійної освіти модератором буде
Наталія Самойленко директорка
навчально-методичного центру
професійно-технічного світу в Сумській
області Це буде відбуватися на другому
поверсі
на третьому насправді поверсі тобто
запам'ятали Але у відкрите програмку Я
вам бажаю зараз спокійно смачного обіду
і хочу ще раз нагадати що після цих
сесії на вас чекає смачний торт будемо
святкувати завершення проекту тому ви
повернетеся в цю зону фуршету і зможете
посмакувати разом відсвяткувати
завершення цього проекту Я вам бажаю
смачного спокійного продовження дня і
було дуже рада бути з вами дякую